référendum en espagne les espagnols ont
dit oui à leur nouvelle constitution 87
% de oui
carter schmitt qu'à la gamme c'est
valéry giscard d'estaing réunion des
quatre grands dans deux mois à la
gouache réactiver la vie rurale c'est la
principale de la politique d'aménagement
du territoire défini par le chef de
l'état les querelles dans la majorité
c'est toujours l'europe qui est en cause
les explications d'alain duhamel
messieurs bonsoir 87 % de oui
incontestablement le référendum espagnol
d'hier est un beau succès pour le régime
de juan carlos et pour le gouvernement
d'adolfo soir est bien sûr c'est à peu
près le même pourcentage qu'au terme des
élections générales il y a un an et demi
mais précisément il est remarquable que
l' enthousiasme des premiers pas dans la
démocratie étant passés les espagnols et
garder à ce point le besoin du consensus
cela dit il y à un point noir dans le
vote d'hier le taux d'abstention et
surtout le taux d'abstention
au pays basque les basques en boudant la
consultation ont refusé assez nettement
la constitution et d'une certaine
manière ils ont refusé leur appartenance
à l'entité espagnol ce sera donc le
problème numéro un du gouvernement
suarez pour les années à nu bonjour
démocratie c'est sans doute le plus beau
titre de la presse madrilène de ce matin
adios franco adios montre aussi
l'impression qu'on tue ceux des
espagnols qui ont voté oui hier de
couper définitivement les ponts avec les
séquelles de la dictature et de
retrouver la liberté
d'une manière générale la presse
souligne aujourd'hui dans tous ces
commentaires
la nette victoire du oui mais aussi
l'importance relative du nom et celle
des abstentions comme prévu le problème
basque s'est très nettement inscrit sur
la carte des résultats 54 % d'abstention
le nom à lui seul recueil plus de 23%
des suffrages
les consignes du parti nationaliste et
de l'extrême gauche basque ont été
particulièrement suivi et ne sont pas
complètement étrangère au fort
sans taj d'abstention enregistré au
niveau national les chiffres sont pris
très au sérieux à madrid mais les
analystes politiques refusent de céder
au catastrophisme
l'abstention du style n'a été utilisée
par les basques que comme une arme en
vue des négociations sur l'élargissement
du statut d'autonomie
bref on refuse de dire que cette
constitution nouvelle a été adopté par
la majorité de l'espagne contre une
seule de ces provinces
beckham et la catalogne et les pays-bas
l'ancien au compteur décès ce qui s'est
passé dans les passes et sont parmi les
régions les plus importants dans la
manifestation favorable
en effet ce qui je crois que les régions
espagnoles les plus importants du point
de vie traditionnel et culturel et
linguistique et politique se sont
retrouvés dans cette nouvelle quotidien
espagnol et je crois que les basques
bon j'arrête voulait après la discussion
d'un statut d'autonomie et vous savez
très bien les gens les nationalistes
basques sont teintées coriace accepter
les choses régler que les pays en
général accepté à main les basques de
fond après est différente je l'espère
avec l'entousiasme que les catalanes les
valenciens mais les autres régions de
l'espagne on manifestait 25 ans 12 pour
la nouvelle constitution qui n'est plus
une peluche centralise mais qui est une
véritable reconstitution de toutes les
régions de l'espace dans un mois tout
juste un sommet à la guadeloupe les 5 et
6 janvier prochain donc c'est à dire la
veille de l'épiphanie les rois mages
sont en fait quatre autour de valéry
giscard d'estaing qui représente la
puissance invitante
jimmy carter helmut schmidt et james
callaghan l'anglais une rencontre
apparaît dans le plus grand secret dont
l'annoncé a surpris aujourd'hui c'est
une idée du président français qui a
bonne il y a 6 mois a constaté que sur
les grands problèmes intestinaux et bien
les responsables occidentaux n'avaient
finalement pas l' approche commune d'où
l'idée d'une rencontre de caractère
personnel sans ordre du jour sans
communiquer de bresse bref comme le dit
valéry giscard d'estaing purement la
rencontre
ce que j'ai proposé de tenir à la
guadeloupe c'est à dire je le sol
français est un me rencontre personnelle
informel dans des conversations sur les
principaux problèmes qui sont apparus
dans le monde en 1978 tout qui
apparaîtront en 1979 où kate les
chroniqueurs de l'actualité dans le
monde
vous avez vu qu'il ya eu de grands
bouleversements d'une modification dans
l' équilibre dans la situation des
différentes régions du monde et c'est
pour faire le point de ces situations
pour les analyser que nous ne réussirons
ensemble mais je vous indique que ce
sont des conversations personnelles et
informel il faut attendre ni décision
que fait l'union
l'apab vocation à prendre ni l'annoncent
ce bien entendu de prises de position
sur ces sujets et pour bien prouver
qu'il s'agit d'une rencontre à caractère
non officiel
on dit que la guadeloupe a été choisie
parce qu'elle mouche mythe et james
callaghan se trouveront en vacances dans
les caraïbes
à ce moment là c'est à dire je le répète
les 5 et 6 janvier
helmut schmidt qui vient à l'instant de
faire une déclaration relative au
conseil européen et aux élections
européennes de juin prochain
le gouvernement reste allemand dit il
n'a pas l'intention de demander une
extension des pouvoirs de ce parlement
qui sera élu au suffrage universel
direct
c'est à vichy que valéry giscard
d'estaing s'est adressé à nos caméras
tout à l'heure vichy où se fêter le
quinzième anniversaire de la datar la
délégation à l'aménagement du territoire
et à l'action régionale en grande
cérémonie des états généraux 15 cents
invités et parmi eux les représentants
de 35 pays pour le chef de l'état qui
présidait les travaux
la france a changé elle a changé
géographiquement elle a changé
économiquement et il lui a signé quatre
grandes orientations
ces changements intervenus dans notre
économie et dans les aspirations des
français conduisent à retenir me
semble-t-il
les quatre orientations nouvelles du
développement régional donner aux
régions en difficulté les moyens de
s'adapter aux changements nécessaires
redistribuer les pouvoirs d'aménagement
du territoire entre les temps et les
collectivités locales de base maintenir
le niveau actuel de la population rurale
et enfin préserver les grands équilibres
naturels de la france et tirer partie de
son espace de son relief et de sa
vocation maritime pour répondre à ses
aspirations
il nous faut à la fois organiser une
france juste ou chaque femme chaque
homme et chaque région ait droit à
l'égalité des chances
bâtir une france forte prêt à faire face
à la compétition de la fin du siècle
autour d'entreprises compétitives dans
l'agriculture l'industrie et le commerce
est protégé pour les 1 re découvrir pour
les autres la douce france qui soit
celle de l'art de vivre inscrits dans
ces monuments
dans ces paysages et dans sa culture sur
un sujet aussi vaste que l'aménagement
du territoire il n'est pas question bien
sûr de chercher dans les propos du
président le surgissement soudain pour
demain d'un territoire nouveau c'est
bien sûr d'orientation qu'il s'agit
d'autre part d'une conférence comme
celle ci qui rassemble quelques 1500
participants il n'est pas question non
plus d'attendre une décision unanime
d'ailleurs la cgt la cfdt et les partis
de gauche ont refusé de participer
officiellement à cette assemblée qu'il
considère comme une opération politique
néanmoins son mettre en cause leurs
appareils différents syndicalistes et
homebrews hommes politiques d'opposition
ont participé à ces travaux sur voulait
toutefois prendre le risque de
rassembler en un seul mot des travaux de
cette vaste assemblée pour l'aménagement
du territoire ce mot serait sans doute
décentralisation pour tous ici est
d'abord pour la datar l'organisme
chargé de l'aménagement du territoire il
s'agira désormais beaucoup plus d'action
locale ponctuelles que de grosses
opérations
en clair et par exemple un peu moins
d'argent pour de nouveaux fos-sur-mer et
un peu plus pour par exemple donner un
petit chat sèche à bon marché dans de
nombreuses communes de montagne alors
j'ajoute très concrètement que le
président de la république a annoncé la
mise en place avant la fin de l'année
c'est à dire dans les semaines à venir
d'une agence nationale pour la création
d'entreprise et qu'il a proposé la
décentralisation en province de
certaines administrations jusque-là
parisien voilà pour l'aménagement du
territoire tel qu'il se présente en
dossiers en fichant carte mais nous
avons voulu ce soir le faire vivre au
quotidien et pour ceux pierre-marie
thiaville et patrice de trades se sont
rendus dans l'aubrac il ya quelques
jours alors que la neige commençait à
tomber
arrive alors pour tous ses habitants une
longue période d'isolement hivernale
c'est cet isolement là qu'il faut briser
et dans ce cas concret l'aménagement du
territoire cela peut vouloir des
réponses
pour vous l'isolément hivernale ce n'est
pas seulement un mot vous le vivez tous
les jours je vais problème c'est un
problème quotidienne quelle maman que
vous voyez aujourd'hui on vient de
mettre les pieds dans la neige et il
faut c'est un handicap pour les gens il
faut bien qu'ils s'en sortent
est ce que dans une commune petit comme
la vôtre vous avez les moyens matériels
et financiers de sortir de cet isolement
un consultant il a un problème on n'en
n'ont pas les moyens on peut pas se
payer les anges les gros un gène que et
elle est pour les chaussées l'équipement
peuvent se payer alors on est moi je
crois que les communes doivent se
tourner vers ce qu'elles peuvent payer
le problème de l' isolement hivernale
donc du déneigement c'est un problème
qui techniquement résolue depuis
longtemps il existe des chasse-neige ou
d'un n'existe pas beaucoup eu de très
gros de très efficace de très puissants
mais aussi le très coûteux
et c'est justement pour essayer de
trouver des moyens qui font moins
coûteux mais tout aussi efficace que
nous avons essayé d'étudier ces
problèmes au niveau des agriculteurs il
faut que les agriculteurs puissent se
servir eux-mêmes d'un matériel plus
pétillant il faut d'abord prises et un
matériel qui soit adaptable sur leurs
tracteurs bataille qu'ils soient peu
coûteux et qu'ils puissent utiliser pour
leur déménagement individuel puisque
notre devise dans ce domaine c est de
toi
la neige c'est de justement l'idéal
c'est encore de le construire sur place
ce matériel c'est parfait ça resserre
sur place
toutes les communes si vous voulez
peuvent pas se payer de grosses machines
donc avec ce matériel là elles peuvent
se dégager et en accueillir plusieurs
qu'est ce qui vous a donné l'idée d'en
construire une vie monde disons que
c'est sur des photos de du canada des
plans on est partis là-dessus vous avait
recopié une machine ça n'a pas été trop
difficile techniquement recopier ce pas
tellement le mot disons que on a reculé
tout puisqu'on n'avait pas aucune côte
on a lancé une fabrication et maintenant
ça marche ça marche
et ça marchera sans doute encore mieux
lorsque les quelques exemplaires
construits par cet artisan local
astucieux ce sera aux multiplier dans
tous les villages et les hameaux où les
gros chasse-neige des nationales n'ont
jamais le loisir de passer
il suffisait d'y penser délire un peu le
constructeur au début est de convaincre
quelques municipalités
c'est ce qu'ont fait les gens de la
datar sur ce plateau d'aubrac tandis
qu'ailleurs on célèbre les exploits du
tgv le train qui roule à 300 à l'heure
ici hier encore il fallait des heures de
travail et des pelles pour atteindre la
route
bien sûr ces petites histoires
d'isolement hivernale et de chasse neige
à bon marché sur l'aubrac lesquin
exemple l on pourrait aussi bien citer
la mise en valeur des terres abandonnées
l'aide aux artisans locaux à l'habitat
rural etc
mais ce qui compte dans cette nouvelle
orientation c'est que pour les gens
d'ici
et pour bien d'autres en france
l'aménagement du territoire et la datar
qui en est chargé commence à signifier
autre chose qu'un mot venus de paris et
qui concerne les autres
et pour en terminer avec l'aménagement
du territoire j'ajoute que pour le
président socialiste du conseil régional
d'auvergne maurice pourchon et bien
cette conférence de vichy et une
opération de prestige qui marque en fait
le coup d'envoi de la campagne
européenne des pouvoirs monsieur pour
champ assisté aux travaux la datar avis
voilà qui nous amène à la politique
politique politicienne diront certains
car tout n'est pas très facile à
comprendre ce soir par très facile de
comprendre la bourse qui se passe au
sein du rpr ou jacques chirac dont une
se confirme qu'il animera une liste
gaulliste pour les élections européennes
du 10 juin souffle le froid et chaud le
froid en condamnant très vivement
voulait d'hier la politique européenne
du chef de l'état jacques chirac s'en
était pris au parti de l'étranger est la
politique de supranationalité et puis le
fonds recommande en même temps au député
rpr de voter un texte qu'ils avaient
refusé la semaine dernière après facile
non plus de comprendre ce qui se passe
au sein de la majorité tout entière
cette fois puisque jean lecanuet qui ce
matin préféré rester silencieux après la
taille de jacques chirac a très vivement
riposté tout à l'heure à l'occasion
d'une conférence de presse il a estimé
que l'outrance des propos de monsieur
chirac était telle qu'il refusait
d'entrer dans une polémique
puis il a ajouté un petit peu plus loin
que il était monstrueux de parler de
démission ou d'inféodation monstrueux
s'aiment pas tellement dans la majorité
en ce moment alors ici on de reprendre
les choses une par une d'abord le
pourquoi la signification la démarche de
jacques chirac à droite ce qui fera
penser que jacques chirac a prononcé sur
un ton qui est extrêmement oppositionnel
il a présenté sur un ton très
oppositionnel un message de principe
alors qu'il est le leader du principal
mouvement la majorité et que ce qui est
important dans cette affaire c'est que
ce texte un texte qui est réfléchie que
cet extrait d'un texte de principe et
qu' il est clair qu'il a naturellement
un aspect qui est un peu chère constant
ciel c'est la réponse pour semer et
c'est le fait qu'il n'est pas satisfait
parce que le président république n'a
pas repris les demandes du repère à ce
sommet mais c'est surtout une prise de
position de fond c'est ça qui compte
il n'accepte pas la même conception de
l'europe que le président l'a alors là
tout parler double jeu parce que pendant
ce temps là jacques chirac a dressé un
autre message aux parlementaires rpr
beaucoup plus conciliant suivi la wii
alors c'est ce que rafa si vous venez
c'est que
je dirais que plus plus il y avait une
divergence visible entre la conception
européenne du président de la république
et la conception européenne du président
du rpr et plus les choses semblent
s'arranger entre le groupe parlementaire
du rpr et entre le premier ministre
apparaît un peu paradoxal en fait vivre
ça n'est pas tout à fait incompatible
dans la mesure où au parlement ce sont
pour l'instant des textes techniques
dont il s'agit c'est donc qu'ils
auraient été ne posez pas devant le
problème de fond c'était beaucoup plus
de questions de forme de courtoisie de
temps à prendre deux choses a expliqué
ses dires de très bonnes choses qui se
passent comme ça
en ce qui concerne le take the shaq est
beaucoup plus important lui c'est une
prise de position deux fonds de
l'assurance
alors du coup après tout celle les
relations internes la majorité n'ont pas
très commode entre rudy harper avait été
français va être extrêmement difficile
pour tout le monde
bon ça va être difficile d'abord pour
les députés rpr puisqu'il est vrai
qu'ils votent avec la majorité au
parlement et qu'ils appartiennent à un
mouvement qui lui expliquent aussi
carrément que possible que les analyses
présidentielle ne sont pas bonnes
c'est pas très facile pour ça va pas
être facile non plus pour les
partenaires de la majorité dans la
mesure où il s'agit vraiment de
l'extrême limite de ce qu'on appelait le
pluralisme organisé ça ne va pas être
très facile encore pour les électeurs du
rpr puisque ce sont des gens dont on ne
se serait même pas les sondages qui sont
favorables à l'unité de la majorité qui
sont favorables aux institutions qui
sont en quelque sorte très souvent des
légitimistes et qui doivent être un peu
perdu
oui ça va pas être facile non plus pour
jacques chirac lui-même après ce qu'il a
dit ne peut pas ne pas y avoir une liste
du rpr naturellement c'est triste il est
évident que c'est lui je ne dis pas
qu'il la dirige en poste à ces attaques
c'est forcément lui qui en animera la
campagne et il animera cette campagne en
étant le chef du principal parti de la
majorité en prenant le contre-pied du
président de la république et du premier
ministre
ça n'est pas totalement évident et tout
ça avec une jambe dans le plâtre autre
répercussion du sommet de bruxelles sur
la politique intérieure française
la réaction de françois mitterrand selon
le premier secrétaire du ps il s'agit
d'un grave échec pour valéry giscard
d'estaing est ce que le président de la
république a bien servi des intérêts de
la france est bien servi les intérêts de
l'europe en faisant des propositions et
en arrêtant des décisions qui ont abouti
finalement allé chez
dans la question que je pose la réponse
est contenue
assurément il a eu tort et en fait cette
grande action diplomatique se tournent
de telle façon que le prestige du
président de la république française se
trouve altérée ce qui n'est jamais
agréable pour un français mais pis
encore les intérêts de notre pays me
semble aujourd'hui compromise par le
résultat des négociations autour des
accords de braine françois mitterrand
qui par ailleurs a évoqué la situation
iranienne toujours devant la presse
étrangère en estimant qu'à moyen terme
les forces populaires iraniennes devait
l'emporter
j'en profite très rapidement pour vous
dire qu en iran précisément 200000
boutiquier viennent d'appeler pour
dimanche prochain à la procession déjà
interdite
il ya tout lieu de penser que cette
journée de dimanche préparait de part et
d'autre dans le pays représentera un
tournant pour le chat et son régime
le coup de boutoir sera certainement
très fort ce jour la déclaration agacé
de jimmy carter tout à l'heure israël et
l'egypte ferait une très grave erreur en
ne signant pas un traité de paix avant
le 17 décembre
simi carter qui a ajouté qu'il était
violemment contre l'établissement de
nouvelles colonies de peuplement juives
sur la rive occidentale du jourdain qui
me carter qui par ailleurs a envoyé son
secrétaire au trésor monsieur blumentahl
en roumanie
est ce vous le savez alors que bucarest
manifeste encore un peu plus qu'à
l'habitude son désir d'indépendance
vis-à-vis du bloc soviétique
et puis un nouveau premier ministre pour
le japon c'est confirmé c'est monsieur
on ira qui remplacera et qui a remplacé
déjà à partir d'aujourd'hui takeo fukui
daf mauritanie maintenant j'apprends à
l'instant par une dépêche de la sp que
le gouvernement mauritanien de monsieur
salek a décidé de libérer une
cinquantaine de prisonniers sahraouis
combattants et civils
libéré il y à une heure tout juste et
répondent en cela à la demande des
envoyés spéciaux d'antenne de conduite
par philippe gassot qu'ils préparaient
un sujet sur la paix dans le monde
une émission dont
vous reparlerons le 18 décembre et qui
avait demandé à monsieur salek de faire
un mouvement de faire un geste
monsieur cela que la fed devant les
caméras vingtaine de il a donc libéré
une cinquantaine de prisonniers du front
polisario
voilà j'en revient maintenant aux
affaires françaises pour évoquer les
propos que raymond barre a tenu ce matin
devant la confédération des syndicats
médicaux
il a surtout été question là cycle des
social dont vous le savez on doit
annoncer la réforme dans les jours à
venir
pour raymond barre on est arrivé à un
point de saturation pour les entreprises
il faut donc mieux répartir la charge
avec l'évolution démographique
défavorable dans les pays industriels
ceux ci ne seront plus en mesure de
supporter une évolution insuffisamment
maîtrisée sur le plan financier de
l'assurance maladie les difficultés
concernent également la france où la
charge globale des cotisations et sa
répartition pèse je l'indiquais tout à
l'heure fortement sur nos entreprises il
y a trente ans mesdames messieurs en
1948 la cotisation qui était alors
unique pour la maladie et la vieillesse
s'élever à 12 % du salaire et était
partagée par moitié entre l'employeur et
le salarié
trente ans plus tard les deux
cotisations additionner sonde 29,10 % et
la part de l'employeur représente plus
des deux tiers de l'ensemble
l'actualité sociale en quelques
télégrammes maintenant poursuite de la
grève au centre de tri postal de
bordeaux après deux d'occupation par les
gravissent suivi chaque fois d'une
évacuation par la police les
négociations avec la direction des
postes sont au point mort et huit mille
sacs de courrier sont en attente
à noter la mise en place d'un centre de
tri parallèle installé par les patrons
de la région ports et docks et bien
nouvelle grève à l'appel des dockers cgt
prévue pour après demain sncf trafic
encore perturbé dans les deux gares dans
deux gares parisiennes paris lyon 1
train sur 4 en circulation aujourd'hui
et paris austerlitz un train sur cinq
enfin journée ville morte à boulogne
aujourd'hui stores baissés magasins
fermés les boulonnais étaient dans la
rue plus de 15000 manifestants avaient
répondu à l'appel de toutes les
centrales syndicales
principale revendication la sauvegarde
de l'emploi dans le boulonnais
un emploi vous le savez gravement
menacée surtout depuis le millier de
licenciements annoncés la semaine
déroule à nice paris ii paris et un
nombre des hauts fourneaux la récession
de la pêche
l'échec de nouvelles implantations une
ville qui fait la morte pour ne pas le
devenir
15 % de demandeurs d'emploi trois fois
plus que la moyenne nationale
parmi eux les 1500 licenciés des
aciéries du trot ils recevront leur
lettre le 15 décembre ils ne savent pas
encore qui sera touché mais la colère
est là ça sera une maison noire dans les
familles il n'a pas d'argent si la paix
ou sur le point de fermer
ce n'est pas avec notre argent on
observe tu nous donnes le salaire des
joueurs la somme de 220 prend 4 221 me
au bout de trente à présent c'est une
honte mais c'est la première fois de
toute ma vie de syndicalistes que je
vous les auriez aussi mécontents et
aussi ils ont pris à faire des choses
même que nature à les retenir
alors le nous en demande que la
situation change et que quelqu'un prenne
position parce que on pourra pas
toujours tenir les deux sociétés ont
pour l'instant proposé de reprendre en
location-gérance les aciéries mais non
sans licencier un millier de personnes
l'état quant à lui puisera dans le fonds
spécial d'adaptation industrielle pour
contribuer à éviter la fermeture en fait
les aciéries oubliés du plan sidérurgie
sont en gros difficile depuis trois ans
il a déjà fallu fermer l'usiné mère
l'année dernière même pas plus at on
parlé dès maintenant c'est un calme
formidable et c'est pour ça que toute la
population les travers des appuis aux
appels 6/7 6/3 et ça qui est aussi c'est
toute une génération de pertes
grand-père deux petits fils qu'ils ont
travaillé le savez même nos vieux qui
passent sur la route ils voient de cette
usine démonter ben salaad
avec 34 ans je suis dans l'usiné et puis
en lisant j ai jamais vu ce qu'il attend
de trouver du travail
vous faites quoi vous vous leur évite
fils mon fils il ya 22 ans il a damé
poids lourd lui à trois victoires et des
mois à 49 ans et si on dit deux
régionaux la région d'hébron possible et
j'ai fait bâtir
j'ai quand même quelques cadres avons
étudié bah c'est pas trop mauvais c'est
ma femme
cl d'eau tiède par bonnet c'est pas moi
si ça veut pas jamais on a rédigé après
que money can à l'acier plus rien c'est
dire enfin si vous mangez que ça va
devenir gênant même s'ils n'osent pas
manger des gosses est belle nous
paraissait se manger français avec
choses ça pollue pertes s'élevaient déjà
révèle marié d'être au chômage quand
jamais jamais jamais eu une vie de
travail parce que c'est beau gâchis
à boulogne pourtant les atouts ne
manquent pas le port des zones
industrielles bien équipé bientôt
l'industrie du froid et sans doute enfin
espère le maire un plan concret de
développement justice avec d'abord ce
procès que l'on travaillait un peu
croquignolesque qui est devenu une
véritable foire d'empoigné je veux
parler du procès charlie hebdo
les dessinateurs de cet hebdomadaire un
petit peu caustique comparaissait pour
injures envers l'armée dessinateur vous
louez croqué par leurs confrères gus le
millier de sympathisants venus soutenir
les inculpés a été refoulé sans
ménagement par les gardes et à digne et
par cette violence dans l'instant
l'enceinte même du palais de justice
magistrats et avocats ont décidé de
reporter toutes les affaires inscrites à
l'audience ce jour quelques instants
après cet incident
on apprenait l'arrestation entre autres
sur le pont saint-michel de ternana de
cabu de reiser ceci dit kass l'air ainsi
que celle du chanteur maxime le
forestier libérés depuis
en fin de compte le procès a été renvoyé
au 22 février ne doit le sport
maintenant avec tout d'abord la voile 21
jours de silence déjà pour alain colas
et toujours rien de nouveau de même que
pour aline le marchand et jacques pallas
aimé ces deux derniers nous possèdent
des bateaux nettement moins rapide que
celui de cola ou 6 et ont moins inquiets
à leur sujet mais rochette les
recherches de la marine nationale se
poursuivent toujours la page de la météo
mais auparavant ce dernier à cette
dernière minute qui nous confirme bien
les difficultés actuelles à l'intérieur
de la majorité toujours à propos de
l'europe alors que je vous parlais tout
à l'heure des propos de jean lecanuet
qui avait estimé un petit peu monstrueux
certain rapprochement de jacques chirac
et bien michel debré pendant ce temps là
sur l'antenne d'europe numéro 1 affirmé
que s'il n'obtenait pas de la part du
gouvernement
les garanties qu'il réclamait pour
l'europe serait avec grand regret obligé
de se séparer de la majorité
la météo donc comme prévu la météo avec
notre ami qui a changé de coiffure pour
la circonstance laurent broomhead
oui bien les jours prochains seront
marqués par un radoucissement des
températures avec un retour des pluies
en effet il règne au dessus de
l'atlantique qu'un grand tourbillon qui
va projeter sur notre pays les vagues
successives de nuit est d'ailleurs
regardez la photographie prise par le
satellite ce matin à 6h weight la france
est à peu près dégager mais on voit
aussi cette masse rouge ce tourbillon
sur l'ouest du pays
alors demain vendredi et bien il fera
encore très froid le matin dans l'est
sur la lorraine l'alsace la franche
comté et les alpes mais des nuages
deviendront sur ces régions si bien que
la nuit suivante c'est bien elle sera
soutenue moins rude
près de la méditerranée bien un ciel
également assez nuageux ce les autres
régions au contraire un ciel très
nuageux et cette fois avec des pluies et
même quelques flocons sur la champagne
et le morvan
attention à des vents de sud fort en mer
je me retourne vers la carte de samedi
cette fois une amélioration du temps sur
l'ouest avec une alternance d'averses et
d'éclaircies d'abord sur la bretagne la
vendée et la normandie puis sur le nord
et le bassin parisien
sur les autres régions et bien encore
beaucoup de nuages avec des pluies
attention tout de même au verglas dans
l'est du pays où la remontée des
températures sera plus lente et moins
sensible merci laurent je suis déjà très
enrhumé 11 16 14
le tiercé d'aujourd'hui avec comme
rapport vous le voyez pour 5 francs 410
francs dans un ordre différent 80 francs
un donc un tout p'tit tiercé qui a
breath l'avait donné d'ailleurs en
quatre chevaux
22h40 sera l'heure de votre dernier
journal présenté ce soir par paire avec
l'aude qui sera précédée d'une page
spéciale buts coupe d'europe de football
point final de la présente édition merci
de votre fidélité
c'est une excellente soirée l écoute de
programmes à demain
à